as of tonight there have been more than
two million recorded deaths from the
coronavirus across the globe
the u.s leading the way in official
rankings with more than 395
90 390 000 fatalities more than 10 and a
half million people have received the
first
dose of the vaccine but only 1.6 million
have gotten the second so far
president-elect biden outlining his plan
to get vaccinations to as many people as
possible
as quickly as possible after he takes
office he's also expressing confidence
about his own safety not from the virus
but
from violent protesters correspondent
peter ducey has the sound tonight
from wilmington delaware the
president-elect was briefed this week
about threats to his inauguration by the
secret service in the fbi
and now he's sharing his takeaway with
fox news
biden was briefed today by his covet 19
team and then expressed confidence in
his plan
to administer 100 million vaccinations
in 100 days
we'll manage the hell out of this
operation even though he admits it's
ambitious
this is a time to set big goals to
pursue them with courage and conviction
because the health of the nation is
literally at stake
his vaccination effort will rely on the
defense production act
to accelerate the making of materials
needed to supply
and administer the vaccine from the
tubes
and and syringes to protective equipment
and the next president stresses
meaningful relief isn't possible
overnight
the policy changes that we're going to
be making
are going to take time to show up in the
coveted statistics
not just statistics it's people's lives
the effort announced today is separate
from his 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package rolled out last night
a two-step plan of rescue and recovery
a two-step plan to build a bridge to the
other side of the crisis we face
to a better stronger more secure america
the next administration is promising to
always be transparent with the american
people
but details about the inaugural address
remain unknown
i could become the shortest live chief
of staff in white house history if i
start to talk about the inaugural
address
this afternoon because it's been a
closely held secret
he's worked on it virtually the entire
transition
biden hinted today he'll take aim at
americans who politicize
mask wearing with a message for those
who refuse to wear them
it's time to grow up we confirmed today
that the current vice president mike
pence and the future vice president
kamala harris have spoken
on the phone it is the first time those
two have talked
that we know about since their
contentious october debate
but since the election neither pence or
trump have reached out to joe biden